[Música]
bajo la luz de la costa azul hay un
pequeño paraíso que poco ha cambiado
desde hace un siglo
[Música]
la ciudad su pequeño Puerto pesquero
su paseo marítimo pero también y sobre
todo su cine evidentemente una sala
mítica por una buena razón es
simplemente el cine más antiguo del
mundo fue aquí en 1895 donde los
espectadores presenciaron la primera
proyección de una imagen animada frente
a este plano la mítica llegada del tren
130 años después Michelle Connie es el
guardián de esta memoria
esta imagen esa tarde en 1895 se mueve
por las personas es ante todo un shock
una emoción pasan por todas las
emociones posibles desde el miedo que
tal vez sea legendario hasta el placer
la diversión
el origen de este Milagro Los hermanos
y esta máquina el cinematógrafo una idea
genial
es una caja que pesa 5 kilos
inicialmente de madera
luego agregaron piezas de metal
el interés de esta caja es que podía al
mismo tiempo grabar y proyectar la
película que habían filmado esta
proyección permite que toda una
población comparta la misma emoción las
mismas risas o los mismos suspiros en
una pantalla
infantil
y la llegada del tren así las primeras
películas de la historia del cine se
proyectaron y rodaron en la ciudad si
este Rincón de la costa azul es hoy la
verdadera cuna del Séptimo arte es
porque los hermanos venían desde Lio a
veranear aquí en el valleduclo de playa
tienen una residencia donde probaron su
cinematografía
pequeñas películas familiares que un día
deciden mostrar a sus vecinos incluidos
Raúl y adeley gallo propietaria de la
identidad teatro bisabuelos de maguire
a finales del verano de 1985 el 21 de
Septiembre actúan el miedo invitó a
todos su personal más un centenar de
habitantes notables de la ciudad a pasar
una velada
toda esta gente se imaginaba viendo
fotos ya que era una familia que ya
había realizado varios inventos
fotográficos
de repente lo que Benson estas fotos
cobrando vida
un descubrimiento que cambiará el curso
de la historia del Teatro el lugar
adquirió notoriedad nacional pero no
solo como cine
hubo peleas de boxeo
muchos espectáculos de musical
y personalidades tan famosas como Edith
por nombrar solo a estos Tres hicieron
un Debut en el edéntico
gracias a su larga historia la sala
incluso concursos de canto emblemáticos
de la década de 1950
Había algo que hoy desapareció pero que
antes era muy famoso
eran los eventos con alguien cantando y
cuando la sala ya no estaba satisfecha
con la actuación de la persona
un gancho salía de atrás de la escena y
llevaba el desafortunado artista Detrás
del escenario
[Música]
fue un gran éxito popular
más que una sala del teatro es un
monumento del patrimonio cultural que
casi desaparece todo cambió una tarde de
diciembre de 1982 cuando el gerente del
cine es asesinado durante un robo
Los matones entraron querían robar el
gerente se resistió y le dispararon este
drama hizo que le den fuera cerrado
durante 30 años
abandonada la sala fue comprada por la
alcaldía y clasificada como monumento
histórico pero la pantalla permanece
desesperadamente negra por falta de un
comprador y eriden está en mal estado
los residentes e incluso Estrellas de la
pantalla grande como Claudia cardinal se
movilizan para salvarlo tenemos que
conservar esto porque es auténtico de la
época los asientos todo es
extraordinario no podemos olvidar los
esfuerzos de toda una comunidad
finalmente dieron sus frutos y en 2013
el cine finalmente es renovado vuelve a
abrir sus puertas al público durante el
la inauguración con bombos y platillos
desde entonces la sala ha vuelto a la
vida ahora ofrece una programación de
arte y ensayo y es la asociación
la que lo opera y también ofrece visitas
guiadas los miércoles y sábado entre las
funciones es Mágico y está imbuido de
muchas emociones para mí porque creo que
hoy en día Cuando haces una película con
tu iPhone no te das cuenta de todo lo
que hubo antes
desde su reapertura el cine ha duplicado
su asistencia cada año 27.000
espectadores acuden a la ciudad al cine
más antiguo del mundo
[Música]